Guardians everything you love
shall be destroyed
screw you you stretch face
RoboCop looking
purple nurple peace um
you don't know you think
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 ready
PG-13 tickets until now wait
way
wait wait
go go
I was eight years old when I left there
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
according to the Galaxy volume three
tickets on sale now hey guess what
Marvel fans tickets are on sale right
now for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
ah Guardians are you ready for one last
ride your favorite group of Misfit
heroes are back as they defend the
Galaxy one last time the stakes
big the action big
and grit
also big he left out some important
information but
that is the gist of it get your tickets
now for Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
only in theaters May 5th